neighborhood clinics emergency rooms and
critical care units in hospitals all
over Chile are struggling to cope with
an epidemic of The Sensational virus
every winter the virus shows its ugly
face it has a high mortality rate in
babies less than a year old but this
year toddlers And even young school
children are becoming seriously ill
outside the calvo McKenna Pediatric
Hospital in Santiago and nanoleiva tells
us that he and his wife have been
sleeping in the halls of the Intensive
Care Unit for a week while their
one-year-old daughter fights for her
life
we've seen some terrible cases yesterday
a baby had respiratory failure the
doctors running around like mad to save
her and were all there watching it's
terrifying for parents
this morning his toddler improved but
many others haven't survived to
infants both two months old were buried
in this Cemetery earlier this month one
because there were no Critical Care beds
left the other because the ambulance
arrived too late
there's no vaccine for this virus that
impacts children under the age of one
the most during the years of pandemic in
which there was a low circulation of
other viruses the normal immunological
cycle was altered creating more
vulnerability
foreign
just like during the coronavirus
pandemic hospitals and staff are
overwhelmed the head of the Pediatric
critical care unit of one of Santiago's
largest private hospitals has turned
this adult intensive care area into a
pediatric wing it is
the worst we've experience since Chile
began recording respiratory viruses and
has been concentrated in a very short
period of time which is why the
Intensive Care beds are full
and to make matters worse the smog
levels here in the valley of Santiago
have increased dramatically this winter
and as we all know that substantially
increases the number of people that
suffer from respiratory diseases both
young and old
that's why something else reminiscent of
the pandemic is back face masks although
not mandatory yet in public transport
the health Ministry is Distributing free
face masks at Metro stations and bus
stations encouraging everyone to use
them again children five and older must
wear them in school
by all accounts it will be a tough
winter for Chileans as they prepare for
the arrival of other seasonal viruses
such as influenza to add to their
respiratory woes
see in human Al Jazeera Santiago